okay so yeah it's a little bit awkward
for me to talk in this session because
while I've worked a lot on quantum error
correcting codes and a little bit on
black holes and while as umer said
there's people that are you know kind of
combining quantum error correction and
holography as the title of this section
suggests i'm not actually one of those
people who's doing any kind of combining
of error correction in holography and so
I don't have anything in particular that
I want to say about that so what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to kind of
talk and feel free to ask questions and
derail me because I'm not really going
anywhere in particular and actually I'm
kind of hoping you derail me so so so to
get started I guess I thought I would
define what a quantum error correcting
code is so that we're all on the same
page so quantum error correcting code
quantum error correcting code is a
subspace of the hilbert space
great okay so it's very simple
definition obviously so the the kaki of
course is that some subspaces will be
really good quantum error correcting
codes and some substances will be bad
quantum error correcting codes no no
this is how I wanted to find it but but
I the very next thing I want to do is
say what it means for quantum error
correcting code to correct errors okay
and then the correction comes into play
so so we're going to let Yi be a set of
errors and these are the the kind of the
set of errors that could occur but I'm
not going to restrict attention to e
being a set of unit Aires it could be
nonunitary errors and so for instance if
you have some some completely positive
map you know there's there's various
cross operators that might occur and
this could be the set of the possible
cross operators or it could be you don't
even know exactly what the completely
positive map is there's just some set of
things that you think might be going on
and for then e could be the set of
linear operators I want them linear
operators acting on the hilbert space of
things that could happen that you want
to correct he is a set of linear
operators that's right he's a set of
linear operators yeah well yeah so
that's the thing I'm going to define now
so so so what does it mean to correct
the set e so we say the the code let's
call it Q corrects errors in E
if so there exists some completely
positive map or so and so this is the
recovery operator fill me why don't I
write that
sucks sad so if we apply our okay so if
psy is in the code and we apply our to
to Esau and we get back the original
state now because I said that II didn't
have to be unitary it could be general
linear operators that's why I need this
proportional here instead of equals
because there could be you know there's
basically some probability that this
particular error e happens oh this right
this is should be true for all e e and E
some probability that's this particular
or e happens which in principle could
depend on exactly what state you have in
the code but in practice if it actually
can correct errors does not depend on
that so there's some probability that's
already happens and that's why this can
be less than 1 right because it's it's
proportional rather than equal okay so
is this definition make sense you can
see here that this is exactly what we
want if an error correcting code that we
have a state some error occurs to it and
then we can get back to where we started
yeah well okay so so so if e really is a
set of all possible errors and we have
this recovery operator R that satisfies
this the property then you always
succeed okay now if if it's possible
that you could have some errors that are
outside of e but maybe with low
probability then you might not know that
that happened and then you can't be sure
that you succeeded
for Sherman no the proportional the
proportional is really all happening
here okay this thing doesn't have
doesn't have trace one anymore okay but
our it's a completely positive trace
preserving map so you're you're getting
back whatever whatever probability there
is still so in this definition it
doesn't have to be a linear space but it
turns out I guess that's worth writing
down let's let's put it up here so it
turns out that if the code Q corrects
sunset II then it also corrects the
linear span of e so you can always
assume it's a linear space so sometimes
it's helpful just to think of kind of
the basis of this linear space sometimes
it's helpful to think of everything just
whatever is most convenient okay and in
fact frequently well okay let me put
that off for a minute okay so maybe let
e let me draw a little picture here so
so the are correcting code as I said is
some some subspace here
and so let's think about what happens
when we have an error well we start with
some some vector in here and the error
might take it outside of this space okay
and then we're trying to project it back
into the space
well not project it rotate it back into
the space okay and so in the example
that I could hear where the dotted line
goes back to the the state that's a
that's a valid error if that's a
correctable error but but there's
definitely things that could happen that
I would not be able to correct right so
give it another color here suppose I had
a different different codeword
represented by this orange thing here
and what I'm trying to do is so I have I
have I have this error space here that
I'm going to rotate back into the
original space right and so this this
orange thing gets moved as well but
suppose it gets moved in a different way
okay and then when I try to rotate back
it goes it goes to the wrong thing okay
so that's an example of how error
correction can sell and so if you if you
if you think about it some more you can
come up with some algebraic conditions
that tell you when a quantum error
correcting code can correct the set of
errors e these are the quantum error
correction conditions and there's a
bunch of forms of these conditions but
maybe I will
Mabel I like one that's kind of most
convenient for what's gonna happen next
so so so let's in this case let ye be
this full linear span so then Q corrects
e if and only if
phone calls so so this would be some
function C that depends on oh yes for
all sigh and for all
Ian F and E so so if you think of
different pairs of errors Eid Agora Ian
Ian F acting on sigh that this
expectation value should not depend on
the state side okay so this form it's
maybe not immediately clear why this
this doesn't happen and why this is this
isn't this is a sufficient and necessary
condition for quantum error correction
but it's this form is going to be easier
to see the next property that I thought
I was going to introduce so right so
then then that still satisfies this
condition because proportional with of
zero factor and and the reason that's
not concerning is because those linear
combinations that occur with zero that
event that annihilated occur was gyro
probability okay so they can never
actually happen to these particular
States okay yes right this is this is
this is true for all sigh in the
subspace sorry a lot of track of where
the question here okay yeah okay
right so so one thing that's maybe worth
noting is that these quantum error
correction conditions are for exact
error correction and they they break
down and stop being useful if you want
to do approximate error correction where
you have some errors and you want to get
back to state but you don't insist that
it be exactly proportional to size you
just be very close to side and in that
case the best the best criterion that I
know to use is an information theoretic
when using something called the coherent
information if the coherent information
is at its maximum value then you can do
perfect our correction if it's close to
the maximum value can do approximate
error correction but if you start to try
to stick an epsilon into this equation
it doesn't doesn't work very well yeah
that's basically the definition though
of recovery right but but I mean the
coherent information kind of is maybe a
little closer to that it's not you're
not directly taking the fidelity but
you're looking at some information
throughout a quantity which is
equivalent in yen yeah
in general that the error can be like a
non-physical error yeah so um so there's
a couple of reasons so one of them is
because of this property it kind of does
really matter so you can you can take
some unitary errors but then you'll get
linear combinations of them that are non
unitary and if I didn't if I didn't
define it to allow that we wouldn't be
seeing that property because you
wouldn't you trying to be taking unitary
combinations and you get something where
it wasn't defined okay and but this is
really an important property that helps
us understand what's going on but the
other reason which is even more
important is that actually even the the
so called non physical errors really are
physical because if you have the CP map
it could be one Crouse operator the CP
map right which is a linear non unitary
operator I mean the overall scale is not
very significant so then basically any
linear operator can be part of a CP map
as a cross operator once you rescale it
appropriately so so really any kind of
linear operator could happen just not
with a hundred percent probability
so okay so then so one one property that
of quantum error correcting codes that
well okay SoDo before I say that I could
so this has been defined really in much
more generality than it ever gets used
well almost ever get used I mean usually
what we do is we work with a case where
the hilbert space the physical hilbert
space has a tensor product structure
like it's a number of qubits for
instance and the errors will have
typically some particular structure as
well they're not just some random
assortment of things so for instance you
might deal with errors that affect one
qubit or one qubit of two qubits or
something like that some limited number
of qubits that's a typical situation but
all of this applies in much more
generality and everything I said so far
it doesn't depend on the tensor product
structure at all and in fact you can
sometimes come up with with interesting
codes that that that don't rely on that
but but but but there's a lot of cases
and really the usual case you do care
about that and in that case it's
frequently convenient to let e be the
set of poly errors for instance acting
on up to up to some number of qubits
that would be one one convenient example
and then the poly errors if you take the
span of them will be all when your
operators acting on T qubits okay so
this is how we can get quantum error
correction codes that will correct you
know a certain number of errors and when
I say certain number of errors I mean
really arbitrary quantum operations that
act on only a limited number of qubits
okay so so one property that starts to
become important in these these these
holography uses and other kinds of uses
that we've seen in in this borderline
quantum information in string theory
field is is the ability to correct
something called erasure errors so
raithra errors really do depend on
tensor product structure and there
instead of saying we want to correct
arbitrary errors that effect T qubits we
say well some number of qubits G qubits
have disappeared okay
they've gotten lost we don't have them
they've been knocked into some state we
know that they're lost so we know where
they are but we don't know I mean we we
know we know which ones are lost but we
don't know what their value is supposed
to be okay
and and that can be easily captured in
these error correction conditions by
saying well okay so since we know which
qubits are lost we only need to think of
Eid AG or F that are acting on those
particular qubits okay and so in that
case e dag or F and but but but they
could be arbitrary on those qubits
because anything could have happened to
them right we don't we don't really know
where they are so in that case the
product e dagger F also obviously acts
on those qubits as well and basically
you can get by by taking the appropriate
span you can get any operator in here
okay and so so so
the upshot of this is that to correct
eraser errors on a set s of cubits we
have the expectation value slide with
any operator acting on s should be
independent of sight okay so what this
is saying is that if we look at row
which is the row S which is the Crace of
sy over the complement of s then this
should be independent and dependent of
the the actual code word sy okay and
frequently when you come up with an
error correcting code this will just be
the maximum mixtape but that's not
essential it just has to be independent
of the logical state okay and remember
these are these are sufficient and
necessary conditions so this is if and
only if so if you have a system and it's
it's there's there's many possible
encoded states spanning some some you
know K dimensional subspace but every
state in that when you look at some some
sub region looks the same that means
that this is a quantum error correcting
code that corrects for a ratio of the
qubits in this sub region okay so so one
way of interpreting this is saying that
that if we take the whole system and we
split it into two parts and one part has
absolutely no information about what the
encoded state is then the other part has
the full information because we can
recover the state
and again it's an if and only if because
if we can recover on this this other
region the original state then that
means that it's an error correcting code
it corrects the rate for error of this
region and therefore this region can't
have any information okay which you know
kind of follows from the no-cloning
theorem but comes out very explicitly in
these are correction conditions so let
me write that down
okay and so that's that's again a
property that gets used over and over
again in these string theory
applications that I've seen okay the
questions have stopped does that mean
I'm saying more interesting stuff for
that you're lost yeah it means it means
this okay so so so if I if I if I take
this the system I break it down into a
tensor product of qubits on s and qubits
on T and the qubits on S well there's
various ways to say it I could say I
randomized them and and you know flip
some flag that tells me I've randomized
them or I've just taken them away or a
variety of other similar things then
using just what's left which means
basically just the qubits on T there
exists some recovery operator that will
give me back the original state that's
right yeah that all this all that
although all the logical states look
exactly the same on us so we have no
idea which one we have well that could
happen also in the quantum case so
here's here's a very simple example
suppose we have a bunch of photons ok
we've encoded the information in the
photons and we send them over some
optical fiber we receive them and we
started with five photons but now we
only have four okay one of them is
missing so that's that's a symbol
outside the alphabet let's say the the
alphabet was you know polarization was
our computational space but the zero
photon state that's different
ventilation channel which is much harder
right yeah yeah so so yeah so this is a
ratio where you know which ones are
missing and nothing else is change this
place that's right but again the
applications that people are interested
in are really something more in the
realm of secret fairing which is closely
related to quantum error correction
where you spread out the qubits and you
have access to some of them you don't
have access to other ones so that's
another example where kind of you know
that they're not there okay so so so
maybe it's worth saying something a
little philosophical here so you can
kind of interpret this as saying that
information is is conserved in a quantum
system right if it's if it's here it's
not there at all and on the other hand
if it's not here then it has to be
somewhere else it has to be over here
okay
now that only really applies if you have
a pure state encoding which is to say
that that you're encoding really
incorporates all the information you
have in smuck some out elsewhere okay so
that that seems very sensible on the
face of it but when you start to dig a
little deeper it can get a little
strange right so for example there's a
five cubic code and this five cubic code
will correct one general R it encodes
one qubit and it can correct to erasure
errors that's the the the part I want to
talk about now and so so so we have
these five cubits if two of them are
absent we can reconstruct this
information okay so so based on that and
and are that that philosophical comment
you might say okay so the information is
present here
okay but of course it corrects for two
arbitrary array curves so we could erase
these two qubits instead and so we might
conclude Oh okay so the information is
present here okay but but these two have
no information about the state right
which kind of indicates that it really
all the information should be present in
this qubit but that's not true either
certainly if that qubit is gone then on
the other four you can you can
reconstruct the original information so
the moral here is that actually this is
true classically as well but the kind of
the information conservation and the
quantum case makes a particular special
it's it's really much more subtle you
can't really say information is present
in any particular place particularly
when you're dealing with something like
a quantum error correcting code it gets
spread out and you can reconstruct it in
various different ways but it's not
localized anywhere okay and that's
something that's can be a bit hard to
wrap your head around and that's
responsible I mean I think Daniels going
to talk about that more right
responsible for some of the weird stuff
that that happens soon is there anything
else I was gonna say about that
okay so in example
well Daniel I think is going to give an
example and I don't want to go into that
much detail in this case it really
explains - okay so the cat state is just
a state so it's maybe not a perfect
example okay so sure sure
so let's look at this subspace so we
have 0 0 + 1 1 + 0 0 minus 1 1 okay and
this is this is supposed to be a
subspace that's actually these are the
basis states okay so now if you just
look at one of these or really even both
of them and you trace over one of the
qubits you'll say okay we have the
identity density matrix right so there
should be no information there so by the
previous argument you might say oh well
I can reconstruct on the other qubit but
you immediately see a problem there
because you take one qubit you
reconstruct you take the other qubit you
reconstruct that's to copy it says to
not be allowed by the no-cloning theorem
and the difficulty here is that this has
to be true for everything in this
subspace everything in the subspace Q
and this is only the basis states that
have the identity density matrix if you
take the sum of them well you get will
you get 0 0 if you take the difference
you get 1 1 and so if you look it gets
the first qubit on this you can easily
tell what you have okay this is an
example of the failure of the quantum
error correction conditions that that
mean that you can't reconstruct the
information that you had in mind okay
now there was another question somewhere
yeah
like you don't know where the error
occurs yeah well okay so there's some
cases where you do know where the error
occurs and that's interesting as well so
the reason was because this is this
array Ferrera property is something that
gets used in these holography examples
whereas the ability to correct general
errors doesn't seem to be used yet as
that I've that I've seen the reason for
that is that to do to do general to
correct general errors you need and so
up if you want if you want to have this
be a process that you're actually doing
to the client computer to correct
general errors you have you always have
to use the oscilloscope operators
whereas an ATS CFT you really don't
think there should be more to the there
should be other degrees of freedom
involved this beyond the CFT everything
everything you describe should just be
taking place I mean well so if you if
you so if you want to if you want to
correct errors in a fault tolerant way
generally you sin so as it turns out
that actually if you just if you're all
you're doing is kind of the pure
communication scenario where alice is
sending qubits to Bob and Alice and Bob
both have perfect quantum computers all
the errors occur in between in the
communication step then Bob actually can
do the recovery operator in place he can
do a decoder that corrects the errors
without using any extra qubits the the
an Silla
are the extra qubits that Alice used to
encode it basically now that's probably
not that relevant to the situation that
you're talking about but I feeling that
it's not really the instill is it's the
if you I think I think it's mostly that
this that this property of information
being spread out is something that's
kind of really important in in a DFT and
because because you have you know you
have this this boundary that has you
think has information localized in
certain ways and a ball which seems like
it could be a totally
current way and and it's playing with
this notion of where the information is
that that I think is really bringing in
the air correction properties an
information spread out phenomenon so
that yeah yeah I but I mean
yeah I mean so if you're doing you know
cryptography and you're interested in
secret sharing and multi-party
computation then again you might be more
interested in the erasure errors but you
know that they don't have to I don't
know it may be that that they will come
to a point where they do want to correct
these more general errors discuss that
today that this is what they've been
worrying about it let's let's leave it
at that maybe okay so let me think so
so
the there's there's a whole theory of
quantum error correcting codes and I'm
really capable of talking for many many
hours about it but I I think maybe the
the next thing to do is to try to make
in MOT what in my mind is a slightly
more explicit connection between error
correcting codes and the way they get
used in Daniels construction and Bart X
construction and and whatever else is
out there and let's erase this so the
the general formalism that that I like
to deal with to to talk about quantum
error correction codes and it's widely
used is called the stabilizer formalism
I don't think I'll go into it since I've
been talking for a while already but the
basic idea is that that we define this
subspace that's the error correcting
code by putting on a set of constraints
with first stabilizer generators and
these are our properties that the error
correcting code is supposed to have okay
and sometimes for a lot of error
correcting code these properties are
kind of many cubed wild properties that
that has kind of our global things and
we're just putting them on for our
convenience because the the resulting
subspace has the right properties to be
good at correcting errors but but you
can also come up with with codes where
that's not true and the constraints that
you're putting on are our local
constraints
and what you can get out of this is
something called an LDPC code
low-density parity-check code so the
power TKE acts are the kinds of
constraints that you're putting on
basically and low-density means that
they're only affecting each one is only
affecting a small fraction of all the
qubits and there's actually another
constraint that makes in another
requirement for an LDPC code which is
that any single qubit is only involved
in a small number of constraints okay
and so the nice thing about an LDPC code
is so we have these constraints and what
if we think of them not as just
mathematical conditions but as terms in
a Hamiltonian okay so we can write some
Hamiltonian which is this sum let's say
have projectors and in an LDPC code each
of these projectors acts only on a few
qubits okay so this is a local
Hamiltonian then making a connection to
kind of the main topic of the the week
but it's also something that that is
kind of physically much more reasonable
right because it's only involving local
stuff and and then the the the code is
the ground subspace of this Hamiltonian
in that case okay so so so how does this
connect to vlog rafi well I don't think
this time well maybe there's some
connection with this Hamiltonian stuff
but mostly I wanted to introduce this
notion of an LDPC code and the
constraints so so in in holography well
the the constructions i've seen with
your kind of toy constructions have
basically what I would call the physical
qubits located on the boundary
or near the boundary if you propose some
sort of cut off to the to the space
because the 80s couldn't show thanks we
go on to infinity not well anyway but
and and and then so the physical qubits
in a quantum error correction code
already contain the whole code right but
there's another side to the code of
course which is the logical qubits and
the constraints okay and taken together
these also define the whole code okay
and in these constructions these logical
qubits and constraints are basically
properties of the bulk okay so this is a
you know very very cartoony version but
I think that's kind of what's going on
in these constructions the constraints
the constraints are not on the boundary
the constraints so okay so I mean maybe
you can actually show any of these codes
okay so but basically the idea is you
have I mean you can think of thing and
the stuff that's happened earlier today
you can think of the encoding circuit is
some sort of mirror or something
and so the logical qubits are living
inside here and every time you add
another you know constraction and Ameri
that's that's basically creating a new
constraint or modifying existing
constraints so it's not it's not quite
this simple and so those things are
living inside two minutes more you
you could say here which would make
things clear to people who know about
encoding yeah so the the logical qubits
are basically some coordinate system on
this encoded subspace they're there
they're not they're not they're not
local on the boundary but but you might
depending on exactly what scheme you
might think of them as being things that
are local inside the bulk okay and the
constraints are the R then R then you
know properties of this space-time that
are somehow fixed and and when you put
these together you get some overall
encoding which is what you see with the
physical qubits and that's kind of the
boundary theory yeah I'm not sure
there's a clear distinction between them
but yeah probably couldn't considered
the encoding circuit I guess the right
creation of time yeah well no no this is
not what this is not in time the
constraints the constraints the
constraints are kind of what's enforcing
the holography because the this the the
statement is that not every possible
state is possible in here right
I'm gonna leave that no no I'm gonna I'm
gonna leave that for Daniel because I I
mean I could draw some pictures but I
don't really know what they mean so the
physical qubit means that it can be
anything because like you know the
physical qubit is what you are encoding
so it's the full space okay sorry so so
what I mean by the the physical qubits
alright so if you have an error
correcting code you take some logical
qubits you run some encoding circuit you
bring in some n Cilla's to run this
encoding circuit you get out the
physical q that's right the physical
qubits are the things that you actually
manipulate for the encoded state the
logical qubits are kind of the
delocalized things that contain the real
information that you care about yeah
yeah okay so there's a very long story
there
so actually coming up they're coming up
with quantum LDPC codes is kind of a
challenge it turns out I mean there are
a bunch of constructions of quantum LDPC
codes based on classical LDPC codes but
there's a phenomenon called degenerate
coding in quantum error correction which
doesn't occur in classical error
correction and LDPC codes just it's
super important and so so it turns out
that classical constructions are
relevant but you kind of need to work
very hard to make sure that you actually
get good quantum error correcting codes
if you start with a kind of true good
classical codes you could it just won't
work depends depends on how what kind of
construction you do there's various
different kinds of constructions but the
most obvious one you can only make a
quantum code if you start with a at
least one of the LDP classical LDPC
codes being bad okay but if you're
clever and how you pick them the quantum
LDPC whether you get out of it can still
be good now there's other constructions
that don't quite work that way but like
I said it's a long story you have a
bunch of qubits on the line and you've
won and you write a stabilizer code
where the stabilizers are locally
generated then the distance is ordered
one on a line yeah no so that okay so
the yes khatai of torque code is a great
example of an LDPC code but there's
there's others so yeah yeah okay that
doesn't that doesn't really matter I
think the the the main thing was this
line one dimension versus two dimensions
you can't really do it in one dimension
in an interesting way and it turns out
that even in true dimensions there's
pretty severe limitations on the
distance versus number of encoded qubits
and in fact in any finite dimension so
if you really want to get okay so we
don't we don't actually know quantum
LDPC codes that have a good ratio of
logical qubits to physical qubits and
correct and I have a distance that's a
constant fraction so distance is
basically the number of errors that can
correct it's twice number of errors that
can occur okay and do you like that the
the fractional distance the distance of
the number of physical qubits could be
good it could be a constant as as the
system gets large because then you can
you know have a have errors occurring
kind of at a constant rate and still be
able to correct them again this is a
long story it turns out that if if
errors are corn gets randomly at a
constant rate we can correct them but
the worst case error if we don't know
how to correct yeah so that's right so
that so so so in two dimensions for
instance the best thing you can do so
you have an L by L system and the best
thing you can do is if if you want to
just encode even just one qubit the best
you can do is have a distance that
squares like L which is the square root
of the number of qubits here okay and
that's not just a tour code has that
property but that's actually the best
you can do in three dimensions and in
three dimensions you can do a bit better
but still still not perfect
yeah
they are related in that locally
correctable codes should be LDPC codes I
think in general locally its are locally
testable codes yeah okay so I yeah so
okay so I'm not exactly sure I guess
what locally correct well locally
testable it could be LDPC codes but okay
okay anyway it sounds like there's
connections but the quantum versions of
these things have only just started to
be studied so in the case of locally
testable codes
yeah if I experience it way to come out
there yes and no so there's there's
various techniques for taking classical
codes and converting them into quantum
codes by now we know a large number of
different quantum codes but in general
finding codes either classical codes or
quantum codes that have some certain set
of properties that's pretty difficult
and is basically there's a there's a lot
of art that goes into finding these
codes
okay well I'll refer I'll refer that to
the other Daniel but this was this was
my version of it which is that the
physical qubits are the boundary the
logical qubits and constraints there the
book was already shocking that we can so
we can reduce the no degrees of freedom
so much you know it doesn't scale like
the volume that you would expect it
alone on and now you're telling us that
in fact even that is redundant we can we
can we can we can download a part of
that area and still recover information
maybe maybe actually actually I would I
would say it the other way is that if
you want to recover information you must
go so part of that if if you just take
an arbitrary state out here well now
your subspace is the whole Hilbert space
and and it won't correct any errors at
all for you know we're almost at that
point so we could just finish this one
which maybe we'll need to postpone again
but but we don't you know there's not a
fixed fixed size of that sphere right
yes not just that this boundary allows
you to be extra trained here where you
have nicely the school and the logical
pivots but in fact this should be true
for every concentric sphere that's right
so really what you have is a family of
codes and different cut-offs that you're
imposing with her I mean it's kind of a
cut-off in length scale that you're not
looking any smaller than that well
that's meaning if you if you look at
smaller and smaller scales it's going to
be more and more pieces rights as more
and more cubits as we have a family of
codes that are all kind of consistent
with each other that are representing
this this change gonna cut off okay
so who's in charge of the time here
let's see here pretty much at the end of
this this session is a couple of final
questions otherwise we'll move on to the
next talk in this yes just ask about
this insult to injury so if you are
looking at the set of states that obey
the States but okay so they don't they
don't formally in our subspace but it's
a smaller set of states so so that's
what when we are saying that so this so
even a subset of that that we can
express accident that so our code is
gonna be a subset of death in this
particular in this particular case yeah
yeah I mean obviously in general quantum
error correction codes don't have to be
very large size which is so again so my
problem is that they don't format in our
subspace because and well a team so so
so so we know we know that if you take a
random state it's not gonna be the area
loss so so the the area law states are
measure zero you say they obey because
it's commuting
sorry I said the general quantum error
correcting code doesn't have to be well
in in this case this the states could
obey an area law right because it's kind
of their right to ask which is like it I
think it's a mathematical nonsense but
let me ask that say if you have outside
Europe and qubits but so now I am just
looking at the set of those states that
away obey the aerial so what would be if
this were a subspace and that's where
the nonsense comes in if this were a
subspace what would be the dimension of
that like spirit of N or I have no idea
I heard that out to the audience I have
no idea this anyone else have an idea
there's a basis of product States no but
in India from idiocy f2 we kind of know
you can organize organize the states by
their total energy into fans labeled by
their total energy and states whose
energy is less than M Squared will obey
the area law and state use n it states
whose energy is greater than N squared
will be volume law so so so that's
that's the answer and what's what's
determining the enter key and it's the
gauge group and it measures the
curvature scale in the boat
yeah I'm just giving you the answer for
a theory with the hook with a gravity
visible I mean I sort of roughly know
the answer in our type models to which
is which is analogous to this I mean it
would you prefer the answer in a
conformal field theory in discrete model
say that there's a the total number of
qubits on the boundaries and then the
number of states which is area law its
dimensionality will be 2 to the some
order one number times then yeah and in
the code I'll talk about the number the
number is 1 over square root of 5 I mean
that's a lower bound I mean maybe it
maybe could be higher but it's at least
1 over square root 5